hoy 9 de noviembre se celebra el día
mundial de la adopción en homenaje a un
acto legal y de amor que permite dar a
niños y jóvenes huérfanos una familia y
también un hogar en este día se pretende
así entonces se crear conciencia y
sensibilizar a la población mundial
acerca de la importancia de la adopción
de acuerdo con cifras estimadas por el
fondo de emergencia de las naciones
unidas para la infancia la unicef más de
150 millones de niños a nivel mundial
necesitan un hogar se destaca además la
cantidad de adolescentes que no han sido
acogidos y adoptados y que al cumplir
los 18 años deben abandonar los centros
de adopción y acogida enfrentándose a la
dura realidad de no haber podido
entonces pertenecer a una familia para
ello quiero darle la bienvenida a
nuestro segundo invitado al día el es
víctor giorgi director del instituto
interamericano del niño la niña y
también el adolescente de la oea gracias
a víctor por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france a 24 que tan
importante es la opción en los niños
además de la importancia de crecer en un
ambiente familiar sano
muy buenos días muchas gracias por la
oportunidad de poder comunicar
los niños necesitan para su desarrollo
vivir en el seno de una familia
esto está planteado incluso a nivel de
documentos internacionales el derecho
del niño a vivir en familia
esto no sólo tiene que haber mala opción
sino que hay una serie de modalidades en
caso de que el niño esté separado de su
familia origen por distintos motivos se
puede llegar a lograr esta situación de
cuidado alternativo de diferente manera
una es la familia llamada familia
extensa abuelos tíos
encontró familiares incluso a veces las
relaciones de la propia comunidad
permiten que sean cargo de estos niños
luego tenemos todo lo que es el
mecanismo de familia solidaridad
familiar adquirida que son familias que
incluye en su vida cotidiana a estos
niños con una posición técnica un
acompañamiento y la adopción es un
mecanismo que se minoritario en cuatro
números e implica la absorción total
digamos del vídeo por parte de la
familia con condiciones derechos legales
similares a un hijo un hijo más
lamentablemente en la región del 60% de
los niños que están separados de su
familia están instituciones nos decimos
instituciones nos referimos a
modalidades de tipo residencial 24 horas
clásicamente se llamaron asilos y que se
ha ido cambiando el nombre pero no tanto
contenido
la adopción es el minoritario y por qué
porque para que se concrete una adopción
se tienen que dar varias circunstancias
en primer lugar tiene que haber una
disolución del vínculo
del niño con sus padres o su familia de
origen que esto es una decisión policial
pero que no es siempre fácil de tomar
porque hay muchas familias que mantienen
relaciones esporádicas parciales
que están separadas por circunstancias
que se supone pueda superarse o sea no
es fácil dos buena decisión judicial de
separación radical del niño de la
familia de segundo lugar se necesita una
familia adoptante que tenga ciertas
características es decir las garantías
al niño y que
acepta ese mismo y aquí hay un problema
muchas veces vemos que hay muchas
familias que buscan adoptar pero también
es cierto que esa opción la quiera
realizar con un niño o una niña que
tenga un cierto perfil niños pequeños
sanos sin antecedentes que puedan
explicar problemas como vih como
adicciones y en la mayoría de los niños
que están hoy por hoy en las
instituciones y condiciones de ser
adoptables no tienen
por encima de 4 o 5 años es muy difícil
con una adopción hay muchos chicos con
discapacidad que hay familias que por
cierto los adoptan pero no son los que
tienen más demanda la adopción
muchas veces se piensa que la baja
adopción es por cuestiones burocráticas
existen pero también hay otras razones
más de fondo que dificultan eso le
quería preguntar víctor qué tan difícil
es en américa latina' poder adoptar un
niño digamos una familia que ya está
preparada ya está lista y decían bueno
es un momento de ampliar nuestra familia
de poder adoptar qué tan difícil es
burocráticamente hacer este trámite
porque tengo entendido que no es tan
fácil
no no era fácil
ahí hay una variedad según el país pero
en general la las leyes que se han
aprobado en los 90 tienden a dar mayor
garantía al niño que se ha adoptado es
decir hay una larga experiencia de
comercialización de niños de adopciones
de niños por motivos no necesariamente
aceptables digamos niños que son del
pueblo han tratado castigados abusados
entonces se han generado a partir de
allí una un endurecimiento debajo de los
requisitos legales para la adopción que
en algunos casos termina siendo un
obstáculo excesivo
pero insisto en que a veces cuando uno
dice hay tantos niños en internados y
porque no los adoptan esos niños no
necesariamente están en condiciones de
ser adoptados e incluso muchas veces las
familias tampoco no hay familias y
encuestas adoptar un caso muy claro son
los pueblos llamados huérfanos de sida
que son niños que perdieron a su padre
por vih algunos de ellos son portadores
y es una población que fue discriminada
y muy difícil de lograr que salgan de
una adopción
hay algo parecido asociar con niños
discapacitados
en general y la familia que quiera
adoptar
tiene la idea de algo muy pareció un
hijo pero un niño pequeño sano y no es
fácil encontrar niños con estos perfiles
y no olvidemos que los niños que sufran
abandono vienen de historias previas
vienen de embarazos complejos rechazados
de madres que no tienen los controles
prenatales
en fin una serie de circunstancias que
hacen que no sea fácil encontrar este
modelo de niños que las familias buscan
para adopción además tenemos que tener
en cuenta que la adopción se apoya en
tres en tres problemas difíciles de
resultar o sea una maternidad no asumida
por estos motivos y causas
el niño vive un abandono y una familia
que viene a rescatar un niño y deseante
es acto de amor si por cierto pero
también por algún tipo de necesidad de
su dinámica y estar ya sea porque no
puede tener hijos ya sea porque sus
hijos se fueron a los tornillos por el
humo y esto genera un nudo estas tres
cosas genera el nudo bastante complejo
de resolver y que requiere un apoyo
técnico y un trabajo muy fuerte de
parteros